we start today with some extraordinarily
sad audio that has been released of a
conversation with Democratic senator
Dianne Feinstein this is a really tough
story to do because this is not an
ageist program in principle and this is
not about ageism this is about
competency
and it appears as though Senator Dianne
Feinstein back from three months out of
the Senate due to health issues has no
memory of having been gone for the last
three months calls for her to resign are
surging again
and we have to be able to you know on
the one hand we have empathy for Dianne
Feinstein and her family and as people
of course and we also recognize that
it is not clear Dianne Feinstein is
currently fit to serve in the United
States Senate now for those of you who
will write in and say David Trump wasn't
fit to serve and he was President for
four years
that's not really what this is about so
we're going to play some audio
there were reports of this conversation
we now have the audio Senator Dianne
Feinstein back from an absence of
several months while battling shingles
is interviewed by Benjamin oreskis of
the Los Angeles Times and she appears to
have no memory whatsoever of having been
away for those three months
anyone's concerned okay
what is the response from your
colleagues been like what are the well
wishes what have you heard what have I
heard about what about your return how
have they felt about you no I haven't
been gone okay
um you should follow me I haven't been
gone I've been working you've been
working from home is what you're saying
oh I've been here
resign
so um at that point Feinstein
um uh whisked away
um Democratic Congressman rocana again
repeats this call for Dianne Feinstein
to resign after this incident uh
sfgate.com reporting rokana was the
first member of Congress to call for
Feinstein's resignation and he is
echoing that call a day after uh
reporters had this encounter where she
appeared to not remember that she had
been absent for three months
uh this is a really tough situation and
it's it's getting ugly and there really
aren't great options and the best option
that many are talking about is that it
is Feinstein's family who should
convince her to resign Gavin Newsom the
governor of California would get to
select a replacement and I don't
remember based on it's in California
whether there is or isn't a special
election depends on the number of days
until the next election I believe
because it's more than six months until
the 2024 election there would be a
special election I think although I may
be wrong we'll double check that but if
it is not
the options according to the U.S
Constitution for removing a senator from
Office are expulsion or resignation and
expulsion would be a formal vote with
two-thirds of the members of the Senate
present and voting
uh in favor of uh of removal resignation
is of course voluntary it doesn't
require a vote it's just up to the
senator and there is no provision for a
recall this is a really sad and tough
situation and as I've said before Dianne
Feinstein has an incredibly storied
career in the Senate she is the longest
serving Democratic member of the Senate
right now and I believe the oldest by by
a few months older than Chuck Grassley
she'll be 90 uh in a few weeks and
this has been going on for years is the
truth okay and at some some point you
have to just say this is what it is
um Dianne Feinstein reportedly
regularly doesn't remember meeting
people that she sees regularly and works
with regularly there are all of these
examples of Dianne Feinstein at Senate
hearings where she will read a question
off of a piece of paper it's not super
clear if she totally gets the question
but after the witness answers she asks
the exact same question a second time
this isn't serving anyone this isn't
serving democracy this isn't serving the
Democratic party who's had judicial uh
nominations from Joe Biden held up
because of Feinstein's absence she's on
the Judiciary Committee so at the end of
the day I don't know what the mechanism
is here
but we have to be able to look at a
situation and assess it for what it is
now people have been writing to me
saying David there should be an upper
limit on age for senators or an upper
limit on the number of years you're
allowed to serve or whatever listen
Maybe maybe those things can all be
explored where we are right now is that
this is the situation and growing calls
for Feinstein to resign the audio is
troubling and it's sad and it's where we
are right now one of our sponsors today
is wild Health founded by two Emergency
Room Physicians wild Health takes your
genetics and your Biometrics and your
lifestyle data to really tailor
suggestions to your exact needs in terms
of nutrition and exercise and sleep and
supplements and all of those things and
the whole idea is just for you to
function at your best it's really a
quite it's a simple goal but it's a
complex goal to achieve you might have a
specific Health goal you want to sleep
better you want to lose weight you want
to stay hell healthy and just feel good
wild health will tailor a care plan with
lifestyle interventions instead of
medications which I prefer as an
approach wild health will pair you with
a care team that includes a
board-certified Precision medicine
physician and accredited health coach
who can receive messages from you
anytime through the app it's fully
virtual telemedicine and if you're
really trying to reach your top physical
and mental condition try wild Health's
premium program at wildhealth.com
premium which includes the white glove
concierge service unlimited visits even
higher touch care these results are
really compelling patients have seen
improvements to diabetic markers reduced
risk of cardiovascular disease reduction
in inflammation and more go to
wildhealth.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 20 off the link is down below
low